[موسيقى]
احبت شابا حملت منه ولم يتمكنا من الزواج
وامام واقع معيشي صعب تعذر الاجهاض سريا
في عياده طبيه هناء المغربيه وهو اسمها
المستعار تروي لنا قصتها مع الاجهاض
بالاعشاب
[موسيقى]
لنشاهد انا السيد اللي كنت معه تعرفت عليه
من الكوليج بقيت معه خمس
سنين ايوا بغيته بغاني كنت كنمشي عنده
للدار كنمشي عنده شحال مره حتى وقع المشكل
حسيت بالاعراض الحمل مشيت وقاللي الطبيب
راك حامله اكد لي الموضوع وجيت جيت هضرت
مع ق شنو كين اشنو كاين قالل احنا ما يمكن
لناش نتزوج دا حيت ماكينش
ماكينش ماكينش باش ووالدينا مايبغي شحال
من
حاجه فكان الحل باش نكمل علاقتنا وك هو
اننا نطيح ذاك الدري
وطحنا ولن انا درتها راسي ماشي مشيت عند
الطبيب ح مشيت عنده طلب واحدمن خيالي
وماشي اي ط يقدر يديرها ح ممنوع في المغرب
مشيت عند واحد العشاب اللي ف مش عن صاحبتي
دت عنده التاج عطاها شي عشوب ح انا خذت
نفس العشوب وخطرت براسي حيت صاحبتي فايت
وقع
ليها قاليها مشاكل بزاف صحتها من بعد ماكت
دوك العشوب خذتهم انا ولكن في الاول كتجي
صحه ولكن من بعد خذتهم ما كامله حتى 12
ساعه طحلي ذاكشي اللي في كرشي ايوا صافي
اللهم تصبر ذاك الوقت ولا تولد الدري وانت
ما عندكش لاش تصرف عليه وما يمكن لكش ما
يمكنك تولد في هذا المجتمع انه يعيش
[موسيقى]
فيه انا بقت في صاحبتي اللي كانت دارت
الخج بديك الطريقه بدوك العشوب شحال من
مره ومن بعد تقاع تزوجت وماك تقدرش تولد
ولا عندها مشكل
في الرحم ديالها وهي باقي كتعاني من
المشكل انا كنت بغيت ذاك الولد وبغيت انني
نولد ويكونوا عندي الدراري حتى انا وتكون
عندي اسره
ولكن ما يمكنش حيت ذاكشي اللي غادي يتعذب
ذاك الدري من بعد ويعيش وسمع ال هضره
مجتمعنا مايرحمش وبزاف المشاكل كتخليك
تقول بلاش منه اللهم ما يجيش ولا يجي
يتعذب وتعذب
معه
دكتور شفيق شريبي السؤال لك يعني تقول هذه
الشابه في شهادتها الطبيب طلب ثمنا خياليا
كي يجهدها بعمليه طبيه اليوم في المجتمع
المغربي وفي الدول العربيه هل تعتبر ان
هناك سوق سوداء لعمليات الاجهاض وما هو
الحل
برايك نعم مع الاسف هناك سوق سوداء لان
الاجهاد هو سري وكل ما هو سري يطلب ثمن
اذا الطبيب سيطلب ثمن
وهذا وهذا الاجهاد مهما هو معمول عند
الطبيب هو معمول ليس معمول في مستش في في
مصحه هو معمول في عياده اي ليس هناك
الظروف الامنه باكملها ولكن اخطر من هذا
وهو هذا الاجهاد التقليدي اللي تكلمت عليه
هذا الفتاه اللي هو اخطر واخطر واخطر ومن
الممكن ان يؤدي الى تس تسمم وهذا التسمم
يمكن ان يؤدي الى وفاه اذا من هذا هو ما
قلت حياه هذه الطفله ولا هذه الفتاه كانت
مهدده مثل حياه ربما الجنين اذا من الاحسن
ان ننقض هذه الطفله او هذه الفتاه ونعمل
ونعمل اجهاد اللي هو اجهاد امن مقنن معمول
في مستشفيات من طرف اطباء اللي عندهم
كفاءه و كل الظروف الامنه لهذا الاجهاد او
توقف امن للحمل طيب جهان جادو يعني انت
ترفضين الجهاد تعتبرين انه جريمه لو كنت
مكان هذه الشابه هذه الشابه يعني حملت ليس
في اطار زواج غلطت غلطت يعني حملت خارج
اطار الزواج لو كنت مكانها ماذا تفعلين
انا لا اعتق تقول انا ظروفي الماديه يعني
لا تسمح لي باجراء عمليه ولا تسمح لي
بانجاب الولد اصلا تقول لا ياتي على ان
ياتي هذا الطفل و تعذب ونتعذب معه نعم انا
لا اعتقد ان اكون يوما في مثل يعني في مثل
هذه شص وكن هذه الامور تحصل في ح تكيد انا
افهم حضرتك بس انا حبيت اوضح شيء طبعا
الاختصاب بكل تاكيد انا ذكرت في الف او
انا مع تقنين لجهاد في حالات معينه اما
تلك الحاله انا اعتقد انها اخطات لماذا
اذا اخطات هي هي والشاب لماذا هم الاثنين
نحن ولكن يعني هي احبت واقامت علاقه حب
انتهينا من هذه المرحله اليوم هناك نتيجه
هي
حامل نعم الحل انها عليها ان تتحمل خطاها
يعني تنجب طفلان
يصح لا بكل تاكيد ان
هناك بعترض يعني المراه لها للمراه حقوق
جنسيه وها حقوق انجابيه وهي الحقوق هي
مقرره دوليا فانا يعني كيف انت بتسمح اذا
الولد نحن بنش تنشئه جنسيه صحيحه من
نل هو التوعيه منذ البدايه
ولي نناقش الاجها هو نتيجه وليس سنناقش
توعيه وجود قانون بحمي مثل ها الحالات هو
الحل
الوحيد
قانون اذا رق اي فتاه اذا رقل اي فتاه ان
تصنع يعني علاقه مع اي شخص من حقها جسدها
ملكها جسدها ليس ملكها وحدها ملك الله
سبحانه وتعالى بكل تاكيد طيب عندي سؤال
عندي سؤال يعني انتم انتما لا تتفقان اصلا
على على الا هناك الحريه الجنسيه التي
تناقشها ارفان وانت تعتبرين ان هذا الامر
يعني لا يجب ان يحصل انا اريد فقط ان
اسالك جيهان اليوم ما الذي يحصل اذا تقنن
الاجهاض في الدول العربيه اذا تقنن
الاجهاد في الوطن العربي سوف تعم الفحشاء
وال ساعطي ساعطي مثالا للمشاهدين ولكم
ضيوف يعني في فرنسا منذ عام 75 الاحصاءات
تشير الى ان سنويا معدل الاجهاضات هو
200000 امراه ولم يتغير ولم يزيد ولم
يرتفع في فرنسا منذ ان تقنن الاجهاض وان
شريعه يعني واليوم في المغرب هناك حديث عن
حوالي 1600 حاله يوميا نعم فانت يعني لا
ربما تفضل دكتور
تفضل هناك هناك ربما 800 حاله او 1 حاله
يوميا والمشكل والمشكل
وهو كل ما شوف الدول كفرنسا او هولندا او
تونس اللي هو الاجهاد مقننا العيه
والبحرين قليل اقل نعم هو اقل واقل واقل
جدا من الدول اللي فيها
الاجهاد غير
مقرم هو مشكل نعم المشكل هو مشكل تربيه
تربيه جنسيه مشكل وهو يجب ان كل فتيات ولا
كل كانت الرجال ايضا لان الرجال يشاركون
في هذه العمليه
فاركون نعم يجب ان يفهموا هذا المشكل و
وهذا تكون الاستاذه اللي تكلموا معها على
يقين بان اذا تقنن سوف لا الارقام سوف لا
ترتفع بالعكس شوف هولندا وشوف فرنسا هذه
الامثله موجوده
جراج فه نحن اس يعني انا بتكلم على الفعل
نفسه الفعل نفسه الاساس اذا كنا سوف نبيح
القتل او قتل الروح يبقى اذا اتكلم عن
كمان للقتل نتيجه ه الموضوع النساء ايض
ايض
تكن بكل اسف اسمحيلي هي اذا كان الطرفين
اذا كان الطرفين اخطاه لماذا هو الجنين
الذي يدفع الثمن واذا تكلمنا لنتحدث عن
هذا تص بالتحديد يعني مساله الروح من
سيتكفل بهذا الجنين من سيتكفل بهذا الطفل
اكفل احنا اذا كنا نحن نتكلم هنا على
الحلول يعني اذا كنا احنا نخرج الان عن
اطار الظاهره و الحلول الحلول الدوله اذا
كانت لبنان بدات بالفعل هذا حل ليست دوله
قدمته في لبنان هي الكنيسه المنظمات
المجتمع المدني عليها بكل تاكيد لانها
تجرم الاجهاض احنا دائما مراه بتتعرض
للعنف دائما بحجه الدين وحجه العادات
والتقاليد يعني مثلا نحن بالوطن الع اعطيك
الكلمه لحظه تفضلي ناران باسم العادات
والتقاليد وباسم الدين دائما النساء عم
تتعرض للعنف ببلادنا العربيه انت بتعتقد
انه في تمييز ضد المراه وفي عنف ولا لا
بكل تاكيد شو نتيجه التنش او العادات
والتقاليد ولا
لا المسؤوليه لماذا المراه انا لم اقول ان
المراه وحدها هي تتحمل مسؤوليه المجتمع
قبل المراه هو الذي تحمل المجتمع في
المجتمع دائما المراه هي اللي تتحمل مسؤول
ولكن ولكن ولكن ربما قد يوافق الكثيرون مع
جهان على ما تقول يعني ان هذا يعتبر ربما
الكثير من الناس يعتبرون انه عمل غير
اخلاقي انه قتل اليوم هل
يعني هل هناك
اجابه تقول انها جريمه هل هناك اجابه على
هذا يعني هل هذا المنطق في النقاش ام لا
لديكم انتم من تدافعون عن الحقوق الفرديه
هي تقول ان ذلك جريم بحق بحق ال س ساعطي
الكلمه للدكتور دكتور تفضل اجب ثم ثم اعود
الفضل نعم اذا شفنا خريطه العالم نشوفوا
بان اكثر من 90% من الدول المتقدمه ا
اباحت الاجهاد و 90% من الدول اللي هي غير
متقدمه او في طريق النمو ا منعت الاجهاد
هل هذه الدول اللي هي المتقدمه هل ليس لها
اخلاق ليس لها دين ليس لها ديونت لوجيا
ليس نعم لها كل هذا ولكن ما لقتش مع الاسف
اي حل وما عندهم اكثر منا عندهم ممكن تكفل
الاطفال عندهم خيات عندهم ومهما ذلك
اباحوا الاجها ربما هذا هذا يعني دكتور
ربما هذا يعني ان ان اليوم هناك ايضا
مسؤوليه سياسيه انت ناشطه حقوقيه انا لست
مع
الاجهاد الام هو المهم ارفان هل هناك
مسؤوليه سياسيه للدوله في هذا الاطار طبعا
هناك مسؤوليه سياسيه للدوله يعني الدوله
لازم هي تامن اول شيء لازم يكون في قانون
ب الجهاض لازم تق ولكن الدين يرفض في
الدول العربيه الاديان كلها ترفض نحن
دائما بتعارض حقوق المراه دائما بتصدم مع
مع التقاليد والعادات ومع الدين نحن ما ما
فينا نحن نبني دوله ديمقراطيه مجتمع
ديمقراطي في عداله في مساواه بدون فصل
الدين عن من حق ان انا اعترض على تلك
الجمله لان كل الاديان التي حرمت الاجهاد
هي تعلم جيدا انها ان الاجهاض في حد ذاته
هو خطر على المراه يعني ليس معنى ان
ر يتم يعني اذا كان اذا كانت المراه اخطات
مره واحده على سبيل المثال في عمرها وانها
ذهبت الى الاجهاد سوف تتكرر هذه هذا الخطا
سوف يتكرر مره واثنين وثلاث طيب يعني تصر
على استخدام كلمه خطا انت تعتبرين انا
اعتبر ذلك هو حق من حقوقها هي تملك جسدها
ولها الحق في التصرف فيه ط دعونا دعونا
نذهب الى اليمن قبل ان نباشر النقاش يعني
اليمن شهادات جديده من اليمن حرب وفقر
ثنائيه قهرت النساء ب درجه اولى فكان
الاجهاد السري هو مخرجه الوحيد ليصبح
الموت في المرصاد مع معدلات مرتفعه جدا
لوفيات الامهات اليمنيات
لنشاهد لا توجد عندنا الحريه انه المراه
تجهض نفسها متى تريد حتى اذا كانت ظروفها
الماديه لا
تسمح فقط المسموح مهو في
حاله الخطوره من الحمل على الصحيه على
المراه او على الجنين احملت وكنت مش قادره
انني اوصل الحمل نظرا لظروف ان الماديه
تعبانه والمعنويه تعبانه فكان معي معروف
صيدلاني فسرب لي ابار الاجهاض تسريب يعني
فاني ضربتهم من نفسي وبمساعده عيال اخي
والاهل دعسوا لبطني وهذا وما تلقني بعدين
رجعت رحت لعند الدكتور وقلت له انه ما
طفلي داخل بطني يعني من نفسه ما انكشفت عن
الموضوع ولا موضوع الصيدلاني وعملي تصفيه
كان الموضوع بالسريه التامه لان ظروفي ما
تسمحش الماديه من غير علم زوجي من غير علم
الاهل لانهم يعني يعاتبوني وهذا فلذلك تم
الامر بموضوع سريه تامه اجهضت اولا لانه
تم حملي باوقات غير مناسبه اول شي الحرب
ثاني شي بنتي عاده صغيره
بالسن ثالث شي زوجي من غير
عمل يعني الا ضع سيئه جدا واهلي نازحين
عني بعيدين واني نازح اصلا في بيت عمي و
بعيد يعني غير بيتي غير مسكني صعب جدا
الحمل وذا ضروا وحدتكم في بيته كيف كانت
طريقه اجهاضي اجهضته اولا بممارسه
التمارين
الرياضيه متمشي الاجهاض تماما بعدين رحت
لعند الدكتوره علشان تشوف حالتي قلت لي
انت بدايه اجهاض جابت لي علاج عشان يسقط
الجنين لان كان شي تعملي اول شي عمليه
تصفيه لاسقاط الجنين ان رفضته قت جيبيلي
بالبدايه علاج عشان اشوف هل بيسقط الجنين
او لا في اسو الاحتمالات انه قد تصاب
المراه بالموت نتيجه النزيف والانتانات
التي لا
تعالج ولهذا مشكله الاجهاضات مشكله خطيره
ولازم يكون للمراه القدره على الحصول على
هذه الخدمه في اسرع
[موسيقى]
وقت
دكتور شفيق شريبي في هذه الشهادات سيدات
متزوجات لجانا الى
الاجهاض بسبب الظروف الاجتماعيه انت من
خلال خبرتك كطبيب نسائي يعني ما الذي يدفع
سيده فعليا الى اختيار
الاجهاض نعم لانها ما يمكن لهاش تكفل ذاك
الطفل لان ظروفها الاجتماعيه او
ظروفها يعني لا تذهب الى عيادتك لقتل روح
فعليا هي لا تذهب بنيه قتل
روح لا هي تذهب لان ظروفها الاجتماعيه
وظروفها كذلك من الناحيه الماليه ما يمكن
لها او ظروف عندهم كل واحده كلها عندها
ظروف وانا كل احترام للسيده اللي هي ضد
الفكره هل ترى الان الان الاجهاد هو ممنوع
ولكن هناك ارقام مهله لان الواحد كما يقول
مثل مغربي كل واحد يحس اللي عنده هو واحد
هذا يحس بواحد القطيب هذا لان المشكل هو
يعيش ذلك المشكل انا مع انا متفق لان اذا
كان ممكن ان لا يكون اجهاد من الاحسن ولكن
هناك ظروف قاسيه وقاسيه جدا تجعل تجعل
هناك نعم في اليمن في اليمن يوميا تموت
امهات بسبب الاجهاض غير غير يعني السري
غير الطبي نعم لان الوضع المعيشي ليس بسبب
علاقه خارج اطار الزواج متزوجات نعم نعم
اذا كنا سوف نحدد قيمه يعني او النسب على
اساس الفقر او على المستوى الاقتصادي او
الاجتماعي الذي ت تعيشه المراه فانا اعتقد
انها نظريه يعني نعم انا اقتنع بانها تكون
ق لكن بكل اسف ليست مبرر اب ابدا على
الاطلاق بسبب لان في مصر اطفال الشوارع
نعم اطفال الشوع ليس بس ليس فقط في مصر
هناك دول عربيه كثيرا تعاني من الفقر لكن
الفقر اذا كنا فتيات في الشوارع فتيات
الشوارع يحملنا في مصر نعم ويلدن اطفال
شوارع نعم ما هو الحل في هذه الحاله انت
ترفضين الاجهاض في هذه الحاله وفي حاله
سيده متزوجه فقيره اي حاله مع اي حل الا
ان تتنصل المراه او ان يكون يعني تصحيح
الخطا خطا اكبر منه لا رضى لحدود الله هذا
القتل هو حد من حدود الله ف يعني لا يجوز
لنا ابدا انت ما تربي الام طفلها كام
عازبه لا لا هذا
نعم لا حضرتك انت تفهمي الفكره بتاعتي انا
اللي اقصده اولا احنا لابد مش عشان ان
احنا يشاع الامور او الاجهاد او ان المراه
تحمل وان يكون لها حق الاختيار في انها
تسقط طفلها يعني احنا دايما بنلق بالفقر
بالعكس هناك اذا على سبيل المثال اذا كان
هناك سرقه لا اسمحيلي ان انا نعم اذا كان
هناك في سرقه بعد اذن حضرتك المفترض ان مش
شرط ابدا يكون ان فقط بس الفقراء هم الذين
يسرقون بالعكس هناك في يعني اسر غنيه جدا
لكن لكل اسف
انا انا اللي عرفت على زميلتنا مع احترامي
الا يعني انه
نه وهي
تعمل الم نعم ما هي
المرجيه ما هي المرجعيه لضمان حقوق المراه
برايك هل هي المرجعيه الدينيه هل هي عادات
وتق كل تاكيد لا لاني انا لا اص هناك
اسمحيلي لا اسمحيلي لا اسمحي ان هناك يعني
انا لاجوز انا يعني اتحدث للاثنين فقط في
نفس الوقت لكن انا بتكلم على شيء مهم جدا
هناك الشرع وهناك القانون فاذا كنا هنحكم
بالشرع يبقى انا بقول لا واذا كنا بنكم
بالقانون حقول ايضا لا لان هذه جريمه قتل
النفس جريمه لا ابدا احد يمكن الجريمه
كذلك نعم والجريمه كذلك وهي ذاك الام
ستقتل وذاك الطفل سيقتل كذلك هذه جريمه
كذلك ولكن من الافضل انا اقول من الافضل
ان نحترم صحه الام وحياه
الامان يعني انت
مدافعه
تقول نعم انا اقول ان المراه تتعرض في
المجتمعات العربيه لتمييز كبير لكثير من
اشكال العنف باسم التقاليد وباسم الدين
ونحن مرجعيتنا لهذه لهذا الحل هو حقوق
الانسان المرجعيه الدوليه لحقوق الانسان
لم حقق الم المراه جته للاديان بسبب الضرب
ضرب او ضرب المبرح للمراه هل ذكر في سؤال
كل الضيوف سابدا معك يا دكتور يعني عندما
نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع نتحدث وكان المراه
هي الطرف المعني الوحيد ونجلد المراه على
هذا الاساس ولا نتحدث عن الرجل انت كطبيب
هل ترى ان هناك دور للرجل في هذا المكان
ام لاكيد نعم طبعا طبعا الرجل له دور ودور
مهم يجب ان ياخذ مسؤوليته المسؤوليه دياله
هو كذلك مسؤول هو من الاحسن اذا كان ممكن
ان يكون تفاهم بين الرجل والمراه ويحتفظون
بهذاك الجنين ويحتفظون بذاك الطفل هذا
احسن واحسن ولكن في اغلب الحالات لا لا
يكون هذا ممكن ه هل ياتي هل ياتي الرجل مع
المراه التي تريد ان تجهد عاده الى
العياده ام لا اغلب الاحيان اغلب الاحيان
لا اغلب الاحيان لا هذا هو المشكل الدراسه
تبين بان اغلب الاحيان الفتاه تذهب الى
طبيب او
تعمل اجهاد تقليدي وحدها واريد ان اقول
شيء اخر وهو
مشكل بفضلك مشكل مشكل مشكل الحمل غير
مرغوب فيه والاجهاد يهم في اغلب الاحيان
الطبقه الكادحه والطبقه الفقيره لان
الطبقه الغنيه ماذا تعمل تاخذ الطائره
وتذهب الى بلاد اخرى وت احصاءات هذا هذا
هذا علمي ما تقوله يعني ام استنتاج من من
عملك هناك احصاءات لا انا اشوف هذا هذا
هذا ماشوفه وهو كاين ثلاث طبقات كين
الطبقه الاولى اللي هي الطبقه الغنيه تاخذ
طائره وتذهب الى بلد اخر وتعمل اجهاض امن
وبكل في ضروف
نعم و ظروف قانونيه كين طبقه ثانيه تذهب
الى طبيب وكن يجب ان تدفع ثمن نعم تدفع
ثمن وهذا الاجهاد هو كذلك ليس امن 100%
طبعا هو كذلك يعرض الطبيب يعرض الطبيب الى
سجون الى السجن والطبقه الثالثه وهي تلك
الطبقه الكادحه الفقيره ما عندهاش اي
وتمشي تعمل اجهاد تقليدي هو من الممكن ان
ت تتسمم
هذا دكتور
الو باختصار شديد باختصار شديد ماذا لو تم
تقنين الاجهاد ماذا لو انا بسال حضرتك
ماذا لو
تم سيكون سيكون سيكون في ظروف بالعكس
تماما سوف تسوء الموضوع ويكون حق لكل
امراه ان ترتكب ما يحلو لها بحكه انها
تقوم
ب
لحظه لحظه لحظه نان تفضلي لا دكتور لحظه ل
لحظه لحظه لسمع
ل
الع
لهل تريم منظمه الصحه العالميه اثبتت
بتونس وتركيا انه عندما قنن الاجهاض بشكل
مطلق وهو حق للنساء قلت عدد م معدل وفيات
وقل حتى نسا بالاجهاض وهي تقرير لمنظمه
الصحه
الع تقن انا انا كنت اريد فقط انا طرحت
السؤال عن دور الرجل جهان انت تحدثتي من
خلال كل هذا الحديث عبر هذه الحلقه يعني
نشعر انك تلومين المراه دائما تقولين
اخطات ارتكبت بالعكس على الاطلا ما هو دور
الرجل برايك دور الرجل هو عليه العقاب
الاكبر لانه هو الذي غرر بتلك المراه
انتقاب تعاقب الافراد ولا ولا تقيم اي
اعتبار لحرياتهم الشخصيه اي حريه شخصيه
التي تقوم على على اساس ارتكاب خطا من
الاساس ال الخطا انها ارتبت انها
شاركت انها شاركت رجل بانها يعني كان شركه
ج لكنها ليست حره في قل اسئله المشاهدين
للاسف دهنا الوقت اسئله المشاهدين على
مواقع التواصل ادم عبد الجبار من الجزائر
سؤال لك نيرفان يقول الاجهاد يعتبر قتلا
الا في الحالات الخطيره التي تؤدي الى
وفاه المراه حينها يجوز الاجهاض والله
اعلم انا عم بقول انه مع انا مع الاجهاض
بالمطلق لا حتى في ما تكون حالات في تقييد
حالات للاجهاض يعني بالمطلق انا مع الاجها
وهو ليس قتلا برايك لا لا يعتبر قتلا طيب
محمد الصافي من السودان السؤال لك جهان
يقول الاجهاد خيار شخصي يخص الزوجين يخص
الزوجين اذا كانوا زوجين فهو يخص الزوجين
لكن ايضا هذا غير غير صحيح على الاطلاق
لانه هناك نصوص اذا نبعد عن مشكله الاديان
ونتكلم في القانون هذا مجرب قانونا الا في
حالات معينه فقط يقول هو خيار شخصي انت
تعتبرين انه ليس خيارا شخصيا هو خيار
اجتماعي لا هو خيار على حسب الشيء الذي
قننا فيه الاديان وايضا القانون جمير
حمدوش من الجزائر والسؤال لك دكتور شريبي
يقول في الاسلام حرام لان الاجهاض
جريمه نعم انا مسلم ولكن لا اريد ان ادخل
في في هذا النقاش هذا نقاش رجال الدين انا
كطبيب اقول الاجهاد ممكن ان يعمل اذا كانت
صحه الام ولكن صحه الام تحديدها حسب
المنظمه العالميه للصحه اذا كانت صحتها
البدنيه والعقليه والاجتماعيه مهدده في من
الممكن ان يعمل توقف امن للحمل اذا هذا هو
وهنا نعم حافظ على هذه الصحه لان هي كلمه
اخيره الصحه العقليه والصحه الجسديه
والصحه هل هذا كافي لحمايه المراه اذا
ارادت اجهاض ه ما هو الحل القانون حل
القانون طبعا تقنين الاجهاض اخر اخر سؤال
يعني هناك الور من السعوديه تقول تقول او
يقول عفوا اي ام لا تستطيع تحمل مسؤوليه
طفلها من حقها اجهاضه لماذا نجلب المزيد
من الضحايا الى العالم اذا كان والدا لا
يريدونه سيقررون بحقه
لك جهان باختصار لكل الضيوف ولك سابدا معك
جهان نعم هذا لماذا نجلب المزيد من
الضحايا يقول لماذا نجلب المزيد من
الضحايا لانها هي التي اخترت ان تاتي بطفل
كضحيه يعني انت تريدين ان ان تحافظي على
عليه كضحيه ولا تقتليه هناك يعني هو الرزق
هذا ملك لله سبحانه وتعالى فقط دكتور
الرزق ملك لله والولد ياتي وتاتي رزقته
معه هذا صحيح نعم انا اقول سيده الان تشوف
الواقع الواقع الان وهو هناك هناك مئات
ومئات عمليات اجهاد مهما ذلك الاجهاد هو
ممنوع ولكن هناك مئات والاف عمليه اجهاض
اذا الان ما هو الحل الحل وهو يجب تقنين
وان يعمل في ظروف طبيه امن وانا على يقين
وانا على يقين بان ارقام الاجهاد ستقفل
لان ستكون تيه جنسيه
انا اوافق الدكتور رايه تماما بما يقول
يجب تقنين الاجهاض ويجب ان لماذا تعتبرين
انت الطفل هو الضحيه ولا تعتبرين الام
التي تذهب الى اجهاض غير امن ليست هي
الضحيه قبلت بالضح ق قل ان المراه هي ضحيه
واقع غرر بها الرجل انا لا القي
طهم غ هذا نقاش اخر هذا نقاش اخر النقاش
مشاهدينا في فلك الممنوع لا نهايه له نترك
لك ولك وللجميع حريه الاختيار وحريه
التفكير فما رايكم تابعونا الخميس المقبل
في عدد جديد من في فلك الممنوع وابقوا
دائما على فونس ك
[موسيقى]
تحياتي